president Trump has just released his
campaign policy platform for
transgenderism and it is simply
magnificent
the left-wing gender Insanity being
pushed in our children is an act of
child abuse very simple
here's my plan to stop the chemical
physical and emotional mutilation of our
youth on day one I will revoke Joe
Biden's cruel policies on so-called
gender affirming care ridiculous a
process that includes giving kids
puberty blockers mutating their physical
appearance and ultimately performing
surgery on minor children can you
believe this I will sign a new executive
order instructing every Federal agency
to cease all programs that promote the
concept of sex and gender transition at
any age I will then ask Congress to
permanently stop Federal taxpayer
dollars from being used to promote or
pay for these procedures and pass a law
prohibiting child sexual mutilation in
all 50 states it'll go very quickly I
will declare that any hospital or health
care provider that participates in the
chemical or physical mutilation of minor
youth will no longer meet federal health
and safety standards for Medicaid and
Medicare and will be terminated from the
program immediately furthermore I will
support the creation of a private right
of action for victims to sue doctors who
have unforgivably performed these
procedures on minor children
so Trump is proposing a private right of
action for any citizen to sue doctors
for transiting the kids but in the first
part Trump makes clear he's not just
talking about banning transgenderism for
kids he's talking about outlawing it
entirely at any age which Trump makes
super clear later in the announcement
we will promote positive education about
the nuclear family the roles of mothers
and fathers and celebrating rather than
erasing the things that make men and
women different and unique I will ask
Congress to pass a bill establishing
that the only genders recognized by the
United States government are male and
female and they are assigned at Birth
what Trump is proposing would
effectively ban transgenderism in all of
its pernicious aspects from every area
of society this is the kind of bold
clear-eyed leadership that reminds me
why I love Trump
it's also the kind of proposal that
reminds me why I love primaries because
Trump is not the first guy to propose
clamping down on the trans nonsense
Governors and state legislators around
the country are right now working to
restrict transgenderism Glenn Younkin
won Virginia on the issue my own state
of Tennessee has just moved forward on
this issue most importantly in this case
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis has won
lots of plaudits on the issue
specifically by restricting transgender
ideology in elementary schools so
since Ron DeSantis is currently Trump's
Chief rival in 2024
Trump now promises to go further much
further than DeSantis has
for now
who knows if and how DeSantis will
respond he might go even further than
that
I know that lots of people don't like
this kind of fighting
lots of people want the 2024 primary to
end before it begins they either want
Trump to drop out and endorse DeSantis
or they want DeSantis to decline to run
and endorse Trump
but one of the best things about
primaries is that they force the
candidates to move further to the right
as they attempt to outflank each other
primaries toughen up the candidates they
reveal potential weaknesses and they
force candidates to take strong
conservative positions to win over the
primary base we are already seeing that
happen in a big way on a very important
issue
and we are still 16 months out from the
Republican National Convention at this
rate with these candidates think of how
much tougher we can make the eventual
nominee before he takes the convention
stage I'm Michael knows this the Michael
null show
evening
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Big G who says
I'm sorry Michael I have to defend
Kamala Harris and I do think she has a
lot to say I credit her for getting my
kindergartner into politics is finally
there as a politician who speaks like a
kindergarten teacher or a kindergarten
student you're so right she does she has
except I don't want to diminish
kindergarten teachers there are many
wonderful kindergarten teachers out
there I I still talk to my kindergarten
teacher I would hate to compare her to
Kamala Harris
but Kamala Harris does she's wow and
then the rocket ship goes well then it
goes up
that's true that's true man it's sort of
like she would be a kindergarten teacher
at a failing Elementary School it's not
good when I think back to my timing
kindergarten I think wow I'm so much
older now I got to make sure that I look
good that I keep staying vibrant and
Youthful that's why you got to check out
genucel I am thrilled to be partnering
with genucel skin care one because the
product is great their most popular
package can take 10 to 15 years off your
skin right now and you can get it for 70
off with their latest breakthrough in
skin care technology a probiotic
moisturizer which is absolutely free
turns out probiotics are not just good
for your gut they're also good for your
skin the other reason I'm so thrilled to
partner though with geniusell is I just
love their story geniusell was founded
by a Coptic Christian in Egypt who left
Egypt to pursue the American dream
he started to formulate his products
when a customer came in and and
requested this one specific ingredient
and he sold it to her at material cost
he never thought he was going to make
money at this he was just he was just
kind of running his shop and then it
became very very popular dermatologists
started calling him about it he's still
involved in formulating all of the
products it's just it's just a wonderful
story a great guy great company so head
on over right now to genucel.com Knowles
for the first time ever every order from
now until Valentine's Day includes a
beauty box with two luxury gifts yours
for free order now because you've only
got two weeks left geniusell.com Knowles
I love it I love that Trump announcement
I know I know every conservative pundit
in America is supposed to hate Trump now
and we're all supposed to say we've got
to move on from Trump he's too old he's
he's terrible we all I'm sorry I love
the guy I'm sorry
don't know what to tell you I really
like the guy I'm not saying he's going
to get the nomination I'm not saying
that the other candidates should drop
out I don't think so at all there's
there are a number of very very strong
Republicans who could make a great
nominee in 2024 right now at this moment
leading the pack in the popular
imagination is is Ron DeSantis he's
doing a great job in Florida
but I'm sorry I just can't I can't
totally throw out Trump he's the best
president in my lifetime
he knocked down Roe v Wade I just I
really like the guy and I like that he
is now staking out a very right-wing
position don't forget when the
transgender question first was posed to
Trump back in 2016.
he kind of punted on it the first time
that that question came up to Trump
they they asked him uh Donald what is
your view on the transgender bathroom
laws in North Carolina
that ban men from going into the women's
bathroom and vice versa and Trump's
answer was not
simply that men shouldn't go into the
girls room that was Ted Cruz's answer
Trump's answer was I don't know what
were they doing before just let's just
keep doing that that seems like it was
fine I don't want to I don't know who
cares about this transgender thing
now though that's a very important issue
potential Rivals like Ron DeSantis have
staked at pretty conservative stances on
that issue and so Trump is moving
further to the right and then you look
down in Florida DeSantis is continuing
to fight on this issue DeSantis is now
promising to stop sex change procedures
on minors
you have and this is sad but this is
going on you're having in our in our
society they're giving
teenagers kids
puberty blockers they're changing
they're they're doing sex change
operations and so we actually have very
you know young adults who went through
this when they were minors and they're
saying this is a huge mistake and in
fact it's not evidence-based when you
start talking about sex changes and
puberty blockers so we've worked through
our department or our medical licensing
board to say that you in the State of
Florida if you're performing those
procedures on these minors you're going
to lose your medical license here in
Florida so that is happening
we're also going to work with the
legislature to make sure that we put
that into statute so that you're able to
have uh have accountability and that's
fear really great stuff if you trans the
kids you're going to lose your medical
license I love this now this position is
not as far right as the as the position
that Trump staked out in that policy
platform
desantis's position is don't trans the
kids Trump's position is don't trans
anybody we're going to Outlaw this
gender ideology everywhere
so the question then that I would have
for DeSantis is
he not going further
out of principle or out of political
necessity
it could be the case that DeSantis is
not going further at least not yet
because
it's very difficult to and there's not a
huge outcry to ban transgenderism
generally the big outcry is to stop it
in in the elementary schools that's why
you had the it was maligned us the don't
say gay bill but its Defenders ended up
calling it The wait till eight bill
which is that you couldn't learn about
transgenderism in elementary schools
until you were in the fourth grade do
you think that's the bar now that we've
said and even that was controversial so
is it is it political necessity if
that's it then I'm and I think DeSantis
is doing a fabulous job
or is DeSantis limiting his attacks on
transgenderism out of principle you've
heard many people say well listen I
don't care if a grown man wants to chop
off his genitals and put on a dress and
call himself Sally that's his right he's
got a right to do that this is America
and if you want to strap on stilettos
and put a little makeup on your giant
Adam's apple and head out there to the
bar and pick up some confused man that's
your right to do it
of course there is no such there you
have no right to change your genitals
you have no right to pretend to be the
opposite sex this has never been
considered to right ever in American
history there have actually been many
laws against this sort of thing even in
Liberal places like San Francisco but if
if that's the principle this kind of
radical libertarian you do you just
don't make me pay for it and don't don't
do it to the kids
that's a little squishy to me that
sounds a little squishy nobody has a
right to transgenderism it's deeply
disordered the people who are doing it
obviously have a lot of problems going
on in their brain they a compassionate
Society will give them help and dispel
their delusions not indulge their
delusions
if it's out of political necessity which
I suspect it is Ron DeSantis is a very
smart guy and I've I've only met him on
one occasion he was very impressive I
watched him give a speech this I felt I
could have written every syllable of
that speech I agreed with it so I think
he's on the right page here but but and
talk is cheap so you can offer a policy
platform but if you're actually doing
something I think that's going to carry
more weight but we've got to suss this
out we've got to make sure in the 2024
primary it is yes of course we shouldn't
trans the kids that should be the base
level but we should go further why
shouldn't we trans the kids because
transgenderism is absurd and wrong and
harmful to everybody and it's an
anthropological lie and and we should
therefore not indulge it for anybody
okay we need to have a sane normal
society
and we need to make sure that whoever is
the eventual nominee recognizes the
problem is not just that we're
transiting the eight-year-olds and they
need to wait till they're 12. we need to
stop tranzing everybody because pretty
soon we're gonna have a trans society
and up is going to be down and left is
going to be right and Truth is going to
be considered falsehood when you're
worried about social turmoil you've got
to check out Jace medical if the past
couple of years has taught us anything
it is that in a crisis like a global
pandemic or natural disaster even the
basics can be very hard to come by
you've got to be prepared for anything
Jace medical is here to help Jace
medical helps you get a long-term supply
of prescription medication their mission
is to empower you to be better medically
prepared a great way to start preparing
is with the Jace case it's a pack of
five different courses of antibiotics
that you can use to treat a whole host
of bacterial illnesses pretty common
stuff UTIs respiratory infections
sinusitis skin infections and more all
you've got to do is fill out a simple
online form in some cases jump on a
quick call with one of their board
certified Physicians from there you can
ask your physician treatment related
questions on an ongoing basis I just
love this I'll put it really bluntly
China invades Taiwan our supply system
is over the supply chain gets broken and
not only are you going to want food and
basic stuff you're going to need
medication just prepare now you've got
to get the Jace case be like the noses
okay I want you to be prepared for
anything go to jacemedical.com code
Knowles at checkout for a discount on
your order that is Jace j-a-s-e
medical.com promo code Knowles
speaking of Florida and and Ron DeSantis
fighting the culture wars you know there
was a story about the AP black studies
curriculum
there's a course out of the College
Board it's for a new AP class
AP stands for advanced placement these
are
supposedly college level classes that
people take in high school but they're
actually just High School classes
they're just
slightly more advanced and so so the
teachers flatter the students by calling
it a college course
but they're taught in high schools this
is for kids 14 years old to 18 years old
and this black studies course
taught all sorts of crazy things
about queer studies about feminist
studies about
anti-whiteness about all the rest of it
and so DeSantis says we're going to boot
this out of Florida high schools
now of course the libs call him a big
terrible racist
but one Florida Democrat County
Commissioner who happens to be a black
man is agreeing with santus
he says this is Leon County Commissioner
Bill Proctor says I think it's trash
there's grave concern about the tone and
the tenor of leadership's voice from the
highest spaces in our state being
hostile to the teaching of
African-American history frankly I'm
against the college board's curriculum I
think it's trash it's not
African-American history it is ideology
I've taught African-American history
I've structured syllabuses for
African-American history I am
African-American history and talking
about queer and feminism and all of that
for the struggle for freedom and
equality and justice
of black history has nothing to do with
queerness and feminist thought at all
totally totally agree he's obviously
right and it shows you
what the Democrats are counting on what
the libs are counting on here is that
they can call anything they want black
they can call anything they want
you know a women's issue they can they
can they can call any crazy thing they
want a civil rights issue and then they
will divide People based on race and sex
so they take this radical course based
on the
cultural developments of 20th century
Western Marxism critical theory which is
what all of these studies courses come
out of and they say okay well we're
going to teach you about weird gay stuff
and weird feminist stuff and all sorts
and anti-white people and to hate
Western Civilization but as long as we
call it black studies no one's going to
be able to criticize it
and then this black County Commissioner
says um I can criticize it why the hell
are you teaching people about weird
queer stuff under the banner of black
studies doesn't make any sense
it's transparent all it requires is a
little bit of Courage from people to say
hold on you're not going to pull the
wool over my eyes don't tell me don't
tell me that pushing transgenderism is
somehow essential to teaching the black
experience in America give me a break
and so the the pushback from the state
obviously starting with the scientists
but other people like this County
Commissioner it's working the College
Board has now revised the black studies
course and and said that they'll tone it
down a little bit so that they're taking
out aspects like black black queer
studies intersectionality and activism
black feminist literary thought the
reparations movement these writers
Kimberly Crenshaw the Communist
terrorist Angela Davis they're they're
now apparently removing all of these
things and adding in new student project
sections that that will replace them
that are somewhat less controversial
this again is is where I I love the
primary process
is don't kid yourself I know DeSantis
hasn't declared he's running yet but he
is practically speaking running for
president right now he's got his
campaign book coming out he is being
attacked by the only declared Republican
candidate right now he's holding press
conferences constantly he's raising a
lot of money so you have to view what's
going on in the State of Florida through
the lens of the 2024 Republican
presidential primary
and that's a good thing I like that
because it's it's DeSantis is already
moving to the right he's already doing a
great job governing Florida this is
going to increase the pressure to go
even further to the right and what I
would say here is
stand firm
black studies has no place in high
schools
women's studies has no place in high
schools none of the critical studies
departments
and pseudo academic disciplines have any
place in high schools
those studies disciplines are are a
thinly veiled uh
ideological
lesson plan for a a
left-wing activism that is grounded in
the western Marxist tradition that's all
it's about
it's about the Frankfurt School it's
about the new left of the 1960s some of
the exponents of the Frankfurt School
like Herbert Mark who is a it's about a
radical uh leftist agenda that says that
that the activists are going to go into
the schools they're going to transform
the common sense they're going to
achieve cultural hegemony and they're
going to have a revolution not by
convincing the workers of the world to
unite and throw off the shackles at the
at the factory but by poisoning the
minds of westerners to hate their own
country to hate their traditions and to
to disavow the greatest achievements of
their culture kick this crap out of the
schools I don't care I'm glad they got
rid of intersectionality lessons in the
class I'm glad they got rid of the weird
queer stuff
it's not enough get rid of the studies
departments
teach history teach English teach math
teach biology teach normal subjects that
will edify students and help their
education all this radical studies kind
of nonsense get it out of there look at
what they're doing at the State
University of New York right now so SUNY
which is the State University up in New
York they've got a lot of campuses
all 64 campuses will now require
freshman students to complete a
diversity Equity inclusion and social
justice course this will be a
requirement for graduation
now you'll you'll hear the squishy
people say well this is this is an
assault on academic freedom
you're going to hear the squishy people
on both sides say that this is an
assault on academic freedom to try to
ban the Dei classes or this is an
assault on academic freedom to require
students to take the Dei classes but I
have no problem with students being
required to take certain classes in fact
I I wish that I had been required to
take more specific classes I wish that
the Common Core Curriculum not common
core like the terrible math program in
schools but I mean the the core the
Western Canon the great books I wish
that were still being mandated in
schools it no longer is I see no problem
with requiring students to take some
classes
they just shouldn't be required to take
these classes
the principle that's operating here in
these liberal schools certainly at the
State University of New York but you're
even seeing it with the movements from
the public schools in Florida and also
around the country it's the same
Principle as a Catholic School requiring
students to take a catechism class
the the Catholics make you learn the
catechism and the libs make you learn
diversity equity and inclusion
it's just the the moral framework the
basics of the faith
for for two different faiths one being
the Christian faith the other being
liberalism being leftism
so that's what they're doing it was
always that way the the universities in
America
all began as seminaries
the really great prominent universities
and they are still seminaries
they're they're just no longer
seminaries for Christianity they're
seminaries for liberalism there are
seminaries for leftism we shouldn't be
shocked when they mandate these kinds of
courses
we should stop it but in order to stop
it we're not going to be able to just
make these weak procedural arguments or
these these abstract arguments about
academic freedom that are ultimately
incoherent especially because academic
freedom is not something that
conservatives traditionally even like
the modern conservative movement was
launched making fun of academic freedom
as I mentioned on the show yesterday
the reason the way that we've got to
stop these courses is by granting the
premise yes the schools have every right
to force students to learn certain
things
just not that
we have to make the argument on the
substance Dei is wrong the black studies
curriculum that is being formulated by a
bunch of Communists to teach students to
become queer and to hate their
civilization that's wrong don't do that
get that out of there
we've got to make sub substantive
arguments conservatives are getting
better and better at doing that this
really began during the Trump era let's
keep it going let's keep the pressure up
you know on Friday I will get to hear
from you in one of my absolute favorite
times of of the whole week that would be
the voicemail bag
some people have written in they're not
quite sure how to submit a voicemail
back question the way you do it you go
to the Daily wire website you go to the
show page you click the Michael Knowles
show
now you're already a member because
you've gone to dailywire.com you've used
code nulls you're a daily wire plus
member you click on submit a mailbag
question it opens up an email
and then you attach your voice file you
can record this voice file on your phone
you can record it on your computer you
can record it on a tape recorder and
then somehow make it digital whatever
you want to do keep it to under one
minute submit it in the email send your
question in and then I will get to hear
your mellifluous dulcet tones
on Friday
speaking of New York
illegal immigration
is not working out so great for a
sanctuary City you know New York said
we're a sanctuary City please come here
surge give us your poor huddled masses
and then the moment that Greg Abbott and
Texas and Rhonda Sanders in Florida
actually ship some immigrants up there
all of a sudden they say well we're
getting too many immigrants cut that out
why are you sending immigrants up here
that's no good and so New York has put
them up in some hotel rooms that the
illegal aliens don't want to leave those
nice hotel rooms now the New Yorkers are
sick of footing the bill for this even
the mayor is starting to pull his hair
out
what is the reality of illegal
immigration what the libs tell us is
illegal immigration is
poor women and widows and orphans and
little doe-eyed dreamers they're just
yearning to be free walking across the
border how dare you turn them away
the reality of what we're seeing in New
York a little bit different
grants we're at your hotel
um actually is the entire hotel from the
third floor to the 28th floor and what
what are you witnessing what did you see
from the migrants that were staying in
your hotel
chaos total chaos I mean there's no
accountability the city is so-called
running the program
um allows these people to destroy these
rooms there is no uh daily supervision
to show these people that this is a
hotel and that you don't destroy the
hotel you're only there temporarily this
is not your home
um unfortunately uh the ones that are
paying the prize is the hotel workers uh
local sex union workers those guys and
those ladies
um endure a lot of disrespect from the
migrants and there is some nice migrants
but there's too much alcohol too much
drugs and too much violence and you have
teenagers you know going into the
staircases and making out and like it's
love is Lane I mean you know this is a
free fall for all
a little bit different than what we're
told by the libs and this is a guy who
is a worker at one of these hotels I
suspect this this man is not racist
against the illegal immigrants this is
not about racism or
anti-hispanic bigotry he's just seeing
what he's seen and he's saying man we
got to stop this this is bad this whole
hotel is full of these migrants
it's mostly if you look at the cameras
it's mostly young men
because
the uh contrary to what we've been told
most of these migrants are not fleeing
political persecution most of these
migrants are not full family units just
seeking a better life it's young men
seeking Economic Opportunity
and they're not behaving in a way that
is particularly respectful of their host
country
obviously not their very first Act
As would-be Americans is to break one of
our most basic laws
not very respectful so the fact that
they're trashing this hotel in New York
not surprising to me at all that's the
reality of it it's very very expensive
for the people of New York and it's
going to be more expensive to fix up
these hotels speaking of expensive
things
Bernie Sanders America's favorite
socialist
has a new event
for his new book
the event in the book are called it's
okay to be angry about capitalism
and if you want to go to the event about
the book about how it's okay to be angry
about capitalism you can do that
for the low low price of 95 dollars
Bernie so he's got cheap tickets too
he's got the 35 tickets but the tickets
go up to 95 dollars this will be hosted
on March first in Washington DC
the book is available from penguin
random house it's 28 dollars it's pretty
expensive for a book wouldn't you say
and penguin writes quote
reflecting on our turbulent times
Senator Sanders takes on the billionaire
class and speaks blunt truths about our
country's failure to address the
destructive nature of a system that is
fueled by uncontrolled greed and rigidly
committed to prioritizing corporate
profits over the needs of ordinary
Americans notice Bernie is no longer
talking about the millionaire class
he used to for most of his political
career he would invade against the
Millionaires and the billionaires and
then a few years ago he dropped the
Millionaire's part
now he only invades against the
billionaires the billionaire class and
the reason for that is
Bernie became a millionaire
and so the moment that Bernie became a
millionaire and then the millionaires
were okay now now it's just the
billionaires pretty much the only bad
people are the people with one dollar
more than Bernie Sanders has
and he's about to get a lot dollars more
many many more dollars than he
previously had because he's going to
sell this book and he's going to sell
tickets to his event now
Bernie does have a slight point he
doesn't know that he has a point but he
does have a slight point
most conservatives looking at this at
least most conservative pundits and
politicians looking at this they're
going to say how dare you Bernie
capitalism is the greatest thing ever
there's nothing wrong with capitalism
we're all Ardent capitalists capitalism
is the greatest thing since life spread
the thesis that Bernie is advancing here
it's okay to be angry about capitalism
he's got a little bit of a point
I don't know when conservatives became
the capitalists we became the promoters
of capitalism or really almost any ISM
whatsoever I'm skeptical of pretty much
all isms and let's not forget capitalism
is a word that was popularized by Karl
Marx okay
what does it mean what is capitalism
there are plenty of problems with
capitalism
if by capitalism we mean
the modern system of Industry the way
that the economy were there are problems
with the way the economy works
now Bernie thinks there's problems with
the way the economy works because he
wants to steal all the money from
anybody who's richer than him and he
wants to flatten out society and he
wants the workers of the world to unite
in a proletarian Communist Revolution
all right that's all wrong but I've got
problems with the way the economy works
I think the way the economy works right
now is rigged against against many good
Americans I think that it can be
terribly destructive to traditional
culture
I think that it is often being wielded
by political Elites who are simply
trying to enrich themselves and grow
their own power
and pursue their own bizarre utopian
Vision rather than actually support the
common good of the United States there's
that's that's plenty true that is plenty
true I think about the the William Blake
poem
Jerusalem where he's which then became a
hymn or he he asks and did those feet in
ancient time walk upon England's
mountains green he's talking about this
Legend the Joseph of Arimathea took
Jesus to England
and he's saying it was the Holy Lamb of
God on England's Pleasant pastures seen
and and then he he you think why is
William Blake talking about this this
wild Legend of Christ in England
and then then he gets to the point in
the second stanza of the poem where he
says
what was was
Jesus actually here in this land
which which we now find ourselves among
these dark satanic Mills that's the
phrase the dark satanic Mills what is
Blake talking about he's talking about
industrialization there are plenty of
dark things about industrialization our
modern industrial society has broken
down the family broken down communities
it's turned us all into Mass consumers
it's made us all very materialistic it's
it's degraded mankind into a kind of
widgets for an assembly line rather than
full integrated human beings
yeah those are real problems
those are totally real problems
I don't think the solution is is
Bernie's Communist Revolution but we can
work on that there are right-wing
critiques of modern capitalism
after all it's a term promoted by Marx
so we don't we don't need to throw the
cultural Improvement out with the Bernie
bath water but we also shouldn't give
him 95 to read a stupid book speaking of
the libs
uh good news though a little bit scary
and MSNBC host is okay she's recovered
but
she just came down with myocarditis this
is a young healthy woman and then with
myocarditis it's kind of weird had you
ever heard the term myocarditis
three or four years ago had you ever
heard that term once in your life I
don't know that I had if I had maybe
once or twice
now we hear it all the time now these
young people seem to come down with it
this is Yasmine vasugyan
she is a very healthy MSNBC host she
received all of her covid booster shots
I'm just mentioning that coincidentally
here's her story
I want to remind you I run seven miles
three to four times a week where I did
um I do yoga I don't eat meat I don't
smoke I drink occasionally not right now
though because my doctor tells me I
can't aside from probably not getting
enough sleep and working too much I'm a
pretty healthy person but on that day I
was anything but my husband drove me to
the emergency room and from there the
nightmare that has been my January began
I was diagnosed with pericarditis
inflammation of the lining of my heart
brought on by a virus a literal common
cold
I also had fluid around my heart that
had to be drained or else it could
hinder the beating of my heart I was
hospitalized for four nights and
transferred from a local hospital to NYU
langone here in New York City on January
4th I was finally discharged after
doctors drained the fluid around my
heart and I bounced out of the hospital
I couldn't get out of there fast enough
with the hopes I was on the mend
but that was not the end three days
later I was readmitted when I felt a
flutter in my heart like a butterfly it
was inside my chest they determined I
had developed myocarditis
she goes on
not just pericarditis myocarditis pretty
pretty scary
how'd she get it a common cold she says
common cold
you'll notice that as the cases of
myocarditis and pericarditis seem to
spike in lots of different populations
they seem to come out of nowhere
everyone shrugs their shoulders they
throw their hands up they say wow gosh
where did this come from and then
they'll start pointing to potential
culprits
could be the common cold
could be the covid virus itself
could be I don't know some people have
suggested eggs I think that I think that
was just a joke that it was the eggs
that gave you myocarditis but they point
to all sorts of there's only one
thing that you are not allowed to
suggest is giving anybody myocarditis
and it happens to be
the the new experimental thing that was
introduced in the last couple of years
you know that thing I don't am I allowed
to say it on YouTube you know that thing
that certain people made other people
get in their arms and but you're we all
know it
we're just not allowed to say it listen
up folks we have been running a massive
40 off sale for annual memberships it
ends tomorrow don't miss the chance to
celebrate one of the greatest moments in
Daily wire history with one of the
greatest offers that's 40 off annual
memberships with code do not comply the
deal ends tomorrow so do not wait one
year ago we sued the government over its
terrible tyrannical vaccine mandate we
won celebrate this Victory with us by
joining the winning team when you join
you get access to the best content and
one of the fastest growing libraries
we're adding a ton of new content this
year with kids more movies and shows
hard-hitting documentaries and more this
is your last chance to get 40 off your
new annual membership at dailywire.com
subscribe use code do not comply CL ends
tomorrow head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe right now lock in your
discount to enjoy all our great releases
coming soon
speaking of vaccines project veritas
speaking of things you're not allowed to
say on YouTube Project Veritas just came
into some apparently leaked guidance
from YouTube after project Veritas
revealed on hidden camera a Pfizer
executive talking about how Pfizer was
planning to engage in gain of function
research directed Evolution research to
beef up viruses to make new vaccines to
make a lot more money
so James O'Keefe and project Veritas
released the video and then
then we find this urgent guidance about
the project very test video what
happened a clip uploaded by project
Veritas featuring a Pfizer official is
rapidly spreading on the platform the
video when uploaded and it's entirely
entirety contains a timestamp that
violates the covid-19 vaccine
misinformation policy for making a
categorical claim that covid-19 vaccines
are ineffective and should therefore be
removed unless it contains sufficient
EDSA CRC
when reviewing
any re-uploads of this content be sure
to confirm that the following violative
time stamp is present
let's quote our undercover journalist
asked Walker have Pfizer is handling the
fact that their coveted vaccines are
ineffective against virus variants what
he said is disturbing listen to this
check the four corners and metadata for
EDSA that clearly contradicts The Violet
of timestamp
and then the action you take is Strike
it
or approve it if it doesn't include that
time stamp why well because of the
misinformation policy okay
so you see the way they're doing it is
they're saying well because of the
context of the narrator
setting up the scene in which the Pfizer
executive admits that the covid vaccines
are
not totally the most effective thing in
the world I don't know what am I
supposed to say to not get another
strike on my YouTube channel
I don't know well whatever it is
that because of that line they're trying
to take the clip down so this raises a
big question
who decides what covid misinformation is
who decides
the Pfizer executive is admitting on
camera that the vaccines don't work the
way we were told they would work
so
if Pfizer can promote misinformation
about covid
who determines true information
fauci wolensky who's the head of the CDC
Joe Biden
they all came out
and they said if you get the fauci ouchy
if you get the shot you will not get
coveted and you will not transmit covet
all three of those people said that
they later admitted that was not true
and I remember when we were covering
this on the show at the time
I quoted them I quoted fauci Biden and
malinsky and I was then told that part
of the show has to be clipped out on
YouTube obviously it could continue to
live on RSS and on The Daily wire plus
but for YouTube it would just be it
would be taken off of YouTube If I
quoted that because it would be
spreading misinformation I said how how
can I receive another strike
for quoting the public health
authorities
well because it's misinformation says
who who determines it I agree fauci's
completely full of it I don't trust a
word he says about public health I agree
same thing with wolenski certainly I
agree with Biden certainly I agree with
Pfizer I agree but now you agree too so
then who's the authority
I think I'm more of an authority than Dr
fauci I think you random Joe I'm
speaking to whichever listener right now
is out in the middle of nowhere with the
absolute least degree of medical
education you I trust more
then I would trust Dr fauci but really
what YouTube is saying here is we
determine it
yeah we pretend that we're just
following the science and the people in
the lab because we don't care what they
have to say if Pfizer says something
that we don't that we don't like or if
we got to bail Pfizer out because they
got caught on a hidden camera then we're
just going to determine it
and we're going to put strikes on you on
your on your channel if you dare to say
it and we're going to censor you we're
going to censor you for paraphrasing if
not quoting out right a Pfizer executive
speaking of censorship meant to get to
the story last week didn't have time
DirecTV has decided to drop Newsmax
you know I love Newsmax I've appeared on
many Newsmax shows this after DirecTV
decided to drop oan another Channel I
like a lot appeared on a lot of oan
shows
why did they do it
well according to DirecTV they say
they're doing it because
Newsmax asked for rate increases which
quote would have led to significantly
higher costs that we would have had to
pass on to the broad customer base
doesn't
seem very credible to me when I think of
the relatively low carry costs for all
of these conservative channels and the
fact that
plenty of TV stations
raise their costs as inflation increases
as their business changes
and DirecTV never seems to to cancel the
liberal channels
DirecTV only which is owned by at T only
cancels the conservative ones
a good example representative Wesley
hunt from Texas Republican in Texas just
pointed this out he said I'm sure
DirecTV will claim that removing Newsmax
from their lineup of channels was purely
a business decision but that's hard to
accept when liberal news channels like
Vice media continue to remain on the air
Vice is a ratings failure for DirecTV
yet they continue to profit from their
relationship with DirecTV so obviously
it's just an attack on conservatives
it's just censorship what do we do about
it
there are not that many TV carriers
what are we going to do are we going to
say well build your own ATT build your
own gigantic
previously build your own State utility
and build your own even private telecoms
company and then buy up your own TV
Network meaning your your own TV service
I don't think so the answer to this used
to be the new media you'd say well just
have your own podcast we'll just have
your own but but even there now a
handful of oligarchs are controlling
that the only answer is political action
look at what Disney's doing right now
one of the stars of a new Disney show
has has just come out to express hope
that the show will appeal to transgender
children by validating their views and
this is a young woman named Zoe to
Rockies she's surgically had her breasts
cut off by some quack doctor she
identifies as quote non-binary and
transmasculine she says I think as trans
people growing up I didn't get to see
myself anywhere so I didn't really know
that I existed
he didn't know you existed
but kojito Ergo soon and especially not
in the hero superhero shower movie and
so I think I just feel deeply grateful
and moved that little trans kids and
trans teens have something to look at
and to know they exist and to know that
they can have superpowers and that's
where we belong so this is obviously
terrible I'm sure the content is going
to be terrible but this is terribly
dangerous content too
this is the sort of content that we
should not allow to Air and there are
two ways to stop this Disney's a big
platform they got a lot of audience so
we can build our own Disney
which we're doing by the way we here
specifically we are doing that here
we're the only group that's doing it to
my knowledge in the in the entire
country so I'm all for that build
Alternatives you have to build Market
alternatives
but that's not enough
it's not enough to say well politics is
Downstream of culture or we just build
your own Disney Builder
it's important to engage in that but
that's not enough we have got to wield
political power to fight this and I
don't care which side of the GOP you are
on
almost everybody seems to be in
agreement
on this point
the real super squishes like ASA
Hutchinson in Arkansas the squishy
Republican Governor there they're not
totally on board but almost everybody to
the right of him is okay this is a great
moment there's a ton of public support
behind this
now is the time to go especially as we
enter the 2024 primary contest every
Republican is going to be trying to
outflank each other to the right good
this can be down to the benefit of the
party base and of the country keep on
pushing guys and wield your political
power to stop this dangerous nonsense
speaking of weird trans queer LGBT stuff
Sam Smith
is a singer I vaguely remember him from
some parties I would go to in New York
as a as a young man in my early 20s but
I haven't kept up with him and since I
listened to Sam Smith he's become a pan
gender or a transgender or I don't know
apparently he's got some really gross
video though so Ben Davies wants to see
how long I can watch this before I throw
a hammer at the TV and turn it off the
rest of the show continues now we've got
a story that I haven't gotten to uh we
will get to that and we will get to all
of your comments so become a member
right now dailywire.com
Knowles kwles use code Knowles at
checkout yet two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign